Speaker 1: The media. Civil War is now
getting really, really interesting as
Donald Trump appears to have completely turned
on Fox News and is now offering to help CNN
crush Fox by becoming conservative, which I know
this is crazy. It sort of seems CNN might be doing
under new leadership. So let's like back it up a
few steps and then we're going to go through this.
First and foremost, there has been a growing
tension, I guess we would call it, between MAGA,
Trump World and Fox News, because there have been
little hints that Fox News is interested in making
the jump away from Trump. Now, if you actually sit
and watch Fox, Fox and Friends or whatever shows.
HANNITY Tucker, they're still very, generally
speaking, deferential to Trump. But I do agree
that Fox News has its finger to the wind and to
some degree, they want a plan in case Trump is not
the Republican nominee in 2024. True, Fox was not
big on Trump at the beginning of the 2016 primary,
and maybe they want to keep their options open.
That is absolutely true. But Trump and other hard
core Trumpists have started to say Fox has
gone woke. Fox has abandoned MAGA. And now
you've got to go to whether it's Newsmax or Oann
or who the hell knows where if you really want
the Trump stuff. So the other part of this
story is that CNN, now under new leadership,
reportedly wants to go more in the direction
of showing both sides or whatever. Now, sadly,
CNN seems to be falling a bit into this kind of
enlightened centrism idea of we must give both
sides on everything. Well, weather report says
it's raining. You'll look out the window and
it is raining. But we need to give the side that
says it's a sunny day. That's idiotic. And that's
the problem that a lot of this enlightened
centrism leads to. But needless to say,
Trump is now jumping into the fray. He posted
on his platform Truth Social. The other day.
Speaker 3: He wrote Essential.
Speaker 1: Quote, Wow. Fox News
is really pushing the Democrats and the Democrat
agenda gets worse every single day. So many Dems
interviewed with only softball questions.
Then Republican counterparts get creamed.
Right now, Karl Rove is unwatchable. Very
negative. And on all the time has a big record of
losing. Not an easy place to be as a Republican,
especially with all the pervert purges. That's
if low ratings CNN ever went conservative. They
would be an absolute goldmine and I would help
them to do so. So this is absolutely fascinating.
The first interesting element of it is
anything but complete. Pray at the
altar of Trump. Deification by Fox
is considered that they've they've turned on
us. They've turned on us, which, of course,
is an absurd standard to stick to if they
want to pretend to be a news organization,
which they do want to pretend to do.
That's on the one hand. On the other hand,
I've talked to you guys so much over the years of
how Trump doesn't really have friends. Trump has
people that he sees as being useful to him, and
so he'll be nice to them. But as soon as they're
not useful, he throws them out and on the other.
And so we've said you can be Trump's best friend.
And the next day if you say something negative
or even neutral about him, you're, you know,
in a dumpster as far as Trump's concerned, look
it out quickly. The opposite is true as well. For
years and years and years, Trump has been deriding
CNN as fake news, enemy of the people, whatever.
And all of a sudden, now that it does sort of
seem like CNN might be taking a sort of a more
right leaning approach and Trump is mad at Fox.
Trump is immediately willing to forgive all of the
anger he's expressed against them, real anger over
the last five, six, seven years. And help them.
And by help them, I assume he means appear on the
network and whatever else. It is truly stunning
and it should not surprise us if you've been
following this. I think the best possible thing
is a Republican civil war. If the media civil
war becomes a part of it, I'm all for it as well.